fue el primer discurso del presidente
joe biden en el departamento de estado
donde además le agradeció a sus
empleados de haber sostenido los últimos
cuatro años bajo el gobierno de donald
trump en su en sus puntos más relevantes
pues le pidió a rusia le pidió al
gobierno de putin que liberara
inmediatamente alexéi navalni y a los
manifestantes que piden su liberación
este es el líder opositor que ha
denunciado varios casos de corrupción en
rusia y pues también el secretario de
estado en línea con el discurso de joe
biden pide además que se vuelva al orden
democrático en rusia también yo bailén
pues se dice que va a poner mano dura a
la guerra económica que trata de librar
china con el mundo pone va a poner las
cartas sobre la mesa sobre qué tan
fuerte va a ser con esa potencia
diciendo que no le asusta lo que está
haciendo china y un punto importante
también resaltar es que
y su asesor para asuntos del hemisferio
occidental
juana gonzález ha dicho que con respecto
a cuba van a volver a rehabilitar los
viajes de estadounidenses a la isla y
también las divisas